[Music]
I identify myself as a black deaf woman
I'm Khalid Chapman I'm from Washington
DC I'm a fifth year student at Gallaudet
University and majoring in government
and considering two minors Public Health
Sciences and criminal justice maybe I'll
run for Congress one day you never know
all deaf individuals can do everything
except hear
[Music]
my first day I was a little taken aback
I was taking it all in
you know just introducing myself to
people Gallaudet is unique because it's
the only one of its kind in the world I
mean the only one it's the only
University for deaf people that provides
education designed specifically for deaf
and hard of hearing students the first
time sometimes people meet a deaf person
they might feel overwhelmed and then
they'll just decide to you know I don't
even want to engage with this deaf
person but I am happy to pull out a pen
and a piece of paper I'm ready to
communicate with anyone who wants to
communicate with me if there's even a
guy who's hitting on me we can write
back and forth that's fine I can even
navigate the dating scene writing notes
with someone who might be interested in
me so that doesn't bother me at all
around seven months old something
happened where I had a hearing loss I
we're not sure if it was due to an
illness but after that I became deaf and
so I began to learn ASL got a cochlear
implant and that led me to Who I am
today oh I remember when I finally came
into the deaf community it was in high
school
and I felt like the deaf community was
something new to me that there was this
whole Deaf world where everyone was
signing you know everyone was
communicating openly and freely with one
another
American Sign Language was first began
by deaf people American Sign Language is
our language research has shown that
many children would benefit from having
as to a visual language either they're
deaf or hearing and it adds a certain
dimension to your brain in terms of the
way your brain processes language
[Music]
Gallaudet University was founded in 1864
so fast forward to 1988 at that time
Gallaudet was a hundred and twenty four
years old and in that a hundred and
twenty four years we had never had a
deaf president leave this institution
[Music]
[Applause]
my role 30 years ago has been one that
I've carried with me throughout that
time I'm part of Gallaudet's history
something that we call deaf president
now DPN which was a movement that
happened here in DC but involved people
throughout the country
[Music]
Gallaudet University had to have a deaf
president because that was the whole
purpose of the university's
establishment in the first place to
advance educational opportunities to
advance the lives of people who were
deaf we closed the gates of the campus
we got a lot of media attention
we had rallies every day sometimes two
or three times a day in fact the effort
grew and it didn't just impact folks
here in the United States it went global
and all of that happened within one
short week we call that that's the week
the world heard Gallaudet
[Music]
[Applause]
I tendered my resignation last night
to pave the way for the Board of
Trustees to consider the selection of a
president who is hearing-impaired
I am thrilled to accept the invitation
of the Board of Trustees to become the
president of Gallaudet University we had
won we won we had made it happen
you know all that hard work can result
in something that was successful and we
proved that to be the case that we made
this enormous impact it was incredible
we've made the first step it's not over
yet this is just the beginning and we'll
keep on making steps until we run and
run it
King had a famous quote and that quote
was shared broadly DPN has inspired me
actually what I learned was that deaf
people really can do anything and
everything and that really inspired me
to get involved in politics because we
don't have any deaf individual at this
time serving in Congress and I want to
be the person that makes that happen you
know maybe by the time I'm 25 who knows
I'm actually the only deaf member of my
family so I come from a hearing family
and I do remember my mom telling me that
when she found out that I was deaf and
had a hearing loss she was a little
taken aback at first you know of course
there's that grief that you experience
because you know she didn't know what to
do with a deaf child sometimes I felt
lonely and isolated you know I was a
deaf student in a hearing classroom and
in a hearing environment I actually went
to three different programs for deaf
students the first that I attended was
an oral program that didn't work out and
then I stopped speech training when I
was in middle school
because I'm a of course I was a
rebellious teenager at that point right
only I didn't want to use my cochlear
implant I thought I was perfectly fine I
knew who I was and I didn't feel like I
needed to hear you know I didn't do that
well in school I was getting in trouble
a lot I wasn't able to participate and
do well in class finish my homework but
once I got to the School for the Deaf it
was like night and day
because of the Milan decision back in
1880 from that point forward deaf
education really did not focus at all on
sign language children were spokes to
only focus on spoken language and so
deaf and hard-of-hearing children who
were trying to sign to communicate with
one another using their hands in any way
for communication were punished we grew
up seeing stories shared by our parents
about them going to work and coming home
having experienced discrimination in the
workplace we could see yet how strong
our parents were badly against
oppression and making their way in the
world very strong-willed and believing
that deaf people could do anything they
set their mind to it
[Music]
the younger deaf population the younger
children these days they don't know this
story and they need to have this story
shared with them it's true I don't hear
certain things that those of you who can
hear are able to hear and yet why should
that be the focus on that deficit way of
thinking when instead we could focus on
all the good that Life brings to people
who can't hear the amazing things that
people who are deaf have as opposed to
focusing on what it is they don't have
this video is part of a larger series on
the deaf community here are some of the
incredible people featured in this
series
subscribe to catch all of these amazing
stories on this season of untold America
and let us know what community we should
cover next